[Music]
right here and gone a bit ready for a
sister's showdown in season 15 of
Keeping Up with the Kardashians in a new
clip things get heated between Kim and
Kourtney when Kim attempts to coordinate
the family's holiday card photo shoot
with a little pushback from her big sis
I'm leaving at 4 p.m. and I don't care
what anyone says
and that's when all hell breaks loose
[Music]
I'm planning it she win the shoot and
while Kris and Kim call Kourtney
annoying
she continues to defend herself business
but you don't that's when Court takes
off and Kim shares this little nugget
about her older sibling I need Kourtney
to not be so annoying with a stick up
her ass like run fish because she
doesn't she's the least exciting to look
at and while Kim may have slimmed her
sis Kris recently told et she's proud of
all her kids I'm proud of all my kids
because they really have an amazing work
ethic and they roll their sleeves up and
really do what they love to do so that
makes me really happy they all find
their passion and when that happens it's
like it's magical
[Music]